4 sur un première jackpot c'est le nom
du nouveau court métrage de benjamin
palier et alexandre gilles est un film
tourné à la smart cities de rambouillet
dans une maison à orcemont un choix du
réalisateur yvelinois j'habite à envoyer
maintenant j'habite à orcemont mais ça
fait 15 ans que je suis de rambouillet
et que je tourne la plupart de mes films
sur rambouillet hockey des lieux comme
le passage fleury le manège la place et
l'export sont des lieux qui reviennent
souvent dans mes films
ce court métrage de 2 à 3 minutes est le
cinquième film du duo de réalisateurs
c'est une comédie aux allures de cartoon
si nous rajoutons c'est un accro du jeu
qui passe son temps à perdre
enfin c'est ce qu'on reprend et qui pour
essayer de trouver les bons numéros du
loto
voilà du jackpot pour décrocher le
jackpot va voir un voyant pour essayer
de décrocher les bons numéros du
prochain tirage qui a une super cagnotte
et là le voyant lui donne les six
numéros qui vont changer sa vie
pour ce film les deux réalisateurs ont
choisi daniel jean colloredo comme
acteur principal
vous avez pu l'apercevoir dans la série
humoristique nos chers voisins sur tf1
il a directement accepté la proposition
c'est une espèce de gags ici et tous les
deux benjamins et alexandre tourner ça
comme un cartoon avec
avec des images cartoon syncopé à rythme
et beaucoup de couleurs c'est très drôle
quand ils m'ont gentiment donné le
scénario j'ai adoré d'abord l'idée est
originale
elle est drôle c'est court c'est rapide
c'est comme un petit dessin animé le
court métrage devrait sortir en octobre
prochain pour une diffusion dans les
festivals français et internationaux et
à la télévision